one thing just about everyone in the
Star Wars Universe can agree on is that
you don't want to wind up on the
business end of a lightsaber but as
deadly as these weapons seem some have
lived to tell the tale of being attacked
with one when The Phantom Menace
premiered in 1999 the only thing that
just about every Star Wars fan could
agree on was that Darth Mo was one of
the best parts of the movie his
signature look frightened younger
audiences and his double-bladed
lightsaber changed the game forever
though he doesn't say a whole lot Mo's
Commander presence makes the character
work that final D of the Fate sequence
at the climax of the film proved to all
that this Sith Apprentice was a force to
be reckoned with after killing Jedi
Master Quon Jin in brutal combat more
nearly dispatches a young Obi-Wan Kenobi
as well pinning our hero down M taunts
Kenobi kicking his lightsaber into the
abyss however Obi-Wan surprises Mo and
cuts the Sith literally in two sending
him down into the void for years it
seemed as if Mo was dead though some
Star Wars Legend story claimed he
survived this led to his eventual
Resurrection in Star Wars the Clone Wars
where it was revealed that Mo now a
cyborg remained alive voiced by Sam
Witwer Mo lived on with an intense
hatred for Kenobi and confronted his
Nemesis on numerous occasions Mo also
led the Crimson Dawn criminal syndicut
depicted in Solo but was soon
sidetracked by his revenge eventually Mo
was officially killed by Kenobi and Star
Wars Rebels having finally found
peace few have gone through as pain and
suffering in the Star Wars universe as
Anakin Skywalker be it emotional turmoil
or physical deterioration Anakin has
undergone enough hardship to last two
lifetimes for this reason it's somewhat
fitting that he lived out two lives one
as a Jedi Knight and the other as a Sith
Lord in Attack of the Clones Anakin and
Obi-Wan Engage The Sith Lord Count Dooku
in battle and though the young Padawan
has undergone rigorous training he was
unprepared for this match as master and
Apprentice tackled the Sith Dooku gained
the upper hand and took Anakin's arm off
below the elbow sending the Padawan
backward Dooku would have finished the
job had Master Yoda not arrived in time
to fend off the Sith Lord gaining a
cybernetic limb Anakin recovers from his
wound using his new found robotic parts
for his Advantage during the Clone Wars
he even returns a favor to Dooku twofold
by removing both of the Sith Lord's
hands before decapitating him in Revenge
of the Sith it is only natural he cut
off your arm and you wanted Revenge
unfortunately for the young Jedi later
in the film Anakin takes on his former
Master on the volcanic Planet Mustafa
after a long D Kenobi gains The High
Ground removing both of Anakin's legs
and his remaining arm in the process by
the film's end Anakin is given more
cybernetic Replacements having now
become the Lord Vader we all know
technically Vader also lost yet another
arm to his son Luke in Return of the
Jedi though he didn't live for very long
afterward in The Empire Strikes Back
Luke arrives at Cloud City to save his
friends from Vader's Force choking grasp
only to learn that the entire thing is a
Setter cornered by The Sith Lord Luke
Strikes Back And even lands a blow on
Vader's armor however it isn't enough
and soon Vader overpowers him taking his
right hand in the process just as Anakin
lust his arm to assist Lord in his youth
Luke loses his hand to Darth Vader it's
here that Vader attempts to sway Luke to
the dark side and reveals the young
Jedi's true parentage
no I am your father thankfully Luke
doesn't succumb to the Temptations from
either his father or the emperor that
Anakin once did instead he resists
finding refuge in his love for his
friends however like his father Luke
receives a cybernetic replacement as a
result his wound paired with the capture
of his friend Han Solo serves as a
powerful motivator and Luke acquires all
the skills necessary to become a
full-fledged Jedi Knight by the events
of the Return of the Jedi Luke soon
establishes a new Jedi Order and by the
sequel Trilogy he remains unscarred any
further at least physically thus
removing his Destiny from that of his
father it may be surprising to learn
that Obi-Wan Kenobi has suffered some
pretty deadly lightsaber wounds but fans
of the Star Wars prequel trilogy will
likely remember these scars well durin
the same battle with K Dooku that
resulted in Anakin's arm being chopped
off obi2 was singed by the red blade of
the Sith Lord early in the battle
Skywalker was incapacitated with Force
lightning forcing Kenobi to face off
against a Sith Lord alone given that
this is the second Sith he's face his
training proof true and the Jedi Knight
fends off Dooku for quite a while
unfortunately for Kenobi Dooku does
eventually Prevail and cuts him deep in
the arm and the leg it is after Obi-Wan
is injured that Anakin faces the count
again before losing his arm Yoda then
must rescue the two younger Jedi of
course this isn't the only lightsaber
wound that Obi-Wan endures in the
original Star Wars film A New Hope old
Ben Kenobi faces off against Darth Vader
sacrificing himself to give Luke and his
friends the chance to escape though it's
debatable if the played actually touches
old Ben or if he just disintegrates into
the force he returns as a spirit in the
sequel
nonetheless one of the primary
antagonists from the animated Star Wars
Rebels the grand Inquisitor is at the
top of the food chain among the four
sensitive Jedi assassins known as the
Empire's inquisitorius having been once
trained as a Jedi Temple guard the grand
Inquisitor fell to the dark side and
joined the Galactic Empire after the end
of the Clone Wars committing himself
fully to the service of the Empire
allied with Darth Vader the grand
Inquisitor helped exterminate Jedi all
over at least until the events of the
Obi-Wan Kenobi Series in the Disney Plus
show the grand Inquisitor is seemingly
killed after he's betrayed by raver also
known as the third sister who shoves her
lightsaber through him in order to
surpass him in power as a result Riva is
given his title and he's seemingly
forgotten however it's later revealed
that he survived due to his thirst for
vengeance eventually the grand
Inquisitor is given back his title
serving under Darth Vader once more
Revenge does wonders for the will to
live don't you think since Rebels takes
place after the events of Obi-Wan Kenobi
the grant Inquisitor eventually allows
himself to die in a battle with Ezra
Bridger and Kanan jerus later Rus
revealed that his Spirit was redeemed
and he becomes known as The Sentinel a
spiritual Ally to the
Jedi speaking of inquisitors rever to
survived the lightsaber wound even more
impressively she survived Mortal Kombat
with Darth Vader himself twice in
Obi-Wan Kenobi we learned that Riva was
a young Ling at the Jedi Temple on
corusant when Order 66 was given and she
faced down against Anakin Skywalker as
he slaughtered her peers somehow she
survived being stabbed by the former
Jedi Knight and grew to hate him
deducing that Skywalker and Vader were
one and the same she planned to
assassinate him for Revenge as raver and
Vader battle we see the full scope of
the Sith Lord's power her eventually the
dark lord stabs her again seemingly
killing her now for the second time
however she doesn't die somehow riva's
rage and connection to the dark side of
the force keep her from death and she
soon flees to tne to kill Vader's only
son thankfully she decides again
slaughtering a young boy in the same way
that Vader once attempted to kill her
leaving her story open to be Revisited
again of all the characters on this list
Rea survival is arguably the most
outlandish it's one thing to survive a
lightsaber wound as an adult but as a
young child it seems just a little
far-fetched perhaps the force or the
Obi-Wan Kenobi showrunners have big
plans for her and Star Wars
installments originally a main character
from The Animated Star Wars Rebels saine
Ren is a Mandalorian turn Jedi
Apprentice who goes on a quest to find a
long-lost friend Ezra Bridger in the
Disney plus series Ahsoka having been
trained in the Jedi Arts by Ahsoka Tano
in the Years between Rebels and the
Ahsoka series sine in her former Master
parted ways some time ago however when
Ahsoka needs to help finding Ezra Sabine
jumps back into the fight unfortunately
for Our Heroes they're not the only ones
in need of the map that will help them
find Ezra it turns out the device will
also help some Empire sympathizers find
Grand amiral thraw to get it back dark
Jedi Apprentice Shin harti surprises
Sabine stealing the map and engaging in
a lightsaber door during the battle Shin
stabs Sabine through the GT leaving her
for dead though it might have been easy
to assume the worst the opening of the
very next episode reveals that somehow
saine survived with only a small scar to
show for it strangely unlike others who
have survived such intense lightsaber
wounds saine seems to have needed no
cybernetic implants whether that's true
or not remains to be seen but given the
intensity of the injury it seems like
there should have been some major
repercussions after all it's the same
wounds that killed Quon Jinn in The
Phantom
Menace the only non-force user on this
list General Grievous is a cyborg and a
major figure in the Confederacy of
independent systems a serious Sor in our
hero size throughout the Clone Wars
Grievous actually first appeared in the
original animated Star Wars Clone Wars
series ahead of the release of Revenge
of the Sith by episode 3 General
Grievous was known as a notorious Jedi
killer who would collect their blades as
trophies you're light saers will make a
fine addition to my
collection although he's a major player
in the animated Star Wars of Clone Wars
Grievous's first feature film appearance
also marks his end however he doesn't
die at the wrong end of a Jedi's blade
as a cyborg Grievous has the ability to
withstand plenty of physical damage even
lightsaber strikes while hiding out in a
cave on a far away planet Grievous is
hunted down by Obi-Wan Kenobi who
engages with the Cyborg and destroyed
Army in the battle Obi-Wan successfully
chops off two of the generals for
cybernetic limbs though he suffers no
true injury the loss of his hands
reduces his Effectiveness eventually
Kenobi does kill General Grievous but
not with his lightsaber after losing his
lightsaber in the battle Obi-Wan uses a
blaster to dispatch the separatist
leader despite his Grizzly death during
the same conflict it's not the
lightsaber that kills him making General
Grievous one of the most durable cyborgs
in the Galaxy good thing Obi-Wan took
him out when he
did a direct descendant of Darth Vader
himself Ben solo fought to walk in the
same footsteps as his grandfather after
believing his uncle Jedi Master Luke
Skywalker tried to kill him Ben finds
Refuge with supreme leader snoke a clone
puppet controlled by the resurrected
Palpatine after changing his name to
kylo Ren Ben became the new face of the
first order 30 years after the end of
the Empire the first order had left its
mark on the Galaxy and the new Republic
had all but vanished however a new hero
rose up to battle against the dark side
Ray a young Force sensitive woman who
actually turns out to be the daughter of
a clone of Palpatine Ray forms a strange
bond with kylo Ren that turns slowly
into something more even after their
battle and the rise of Skywalker ends
with Ray stabbing Ren through the gut
that Bond remains using a force healing
technique Ray keeps kylo R from Death
fighting to resurrect Ben solo as well
thankfully she does and the two of them
take on altine together however Ben
eventually Returns the favor to his
friend giving his life in exchange for
race okay this one is a bit of a stretch
but Qui-Gon Jin continues to live on in
some form long after plenty of other
Jedi have perished completely so we
thought it would be fair to give him
some credit here primarily appearing in
The Phantom Menace Qui-Gon trained
Obi-Wan since he was a boy and plans to
train a young Anakin Skywalker as well
unfortunately those plans were foiled by
The Sith after the Trade Federation
invaded na
as we already know Darth Moore dos of
Jin and Kenobi before they're separated
and fatally stabs Quon in the gut Quon
dies shortly thereafter but not before
making Obi-Wan swear to train Anakin as
a Jedi it's not until the very end of
Revenge of the Sith that Qui-Gon is
mentioned again when Yoda reveals to
Obi-Wan that his old master has found a
way to reach out from Beyond to the
grave at the end of obiwan Kenobi Quon
finally reappears to his former
Apprentice ready to teach him the secret
ways of the force so that he too might
one day join him in the the afterlife
admittedly Qui-Gon doesn't technically
survive his lightsaber wound but the
fact that he learns to make himself into
an immortal Spirit following his death
definitely gives him an
[Music]
edge